you
hi everyone is Gerry I'm on leeches org
and I just got paired up playing a 15-2
game so let's throw a have fun my
opponent G King okay so French defense
okay I'll go down this path I do have it
I did have an option for d3 and maybe I
turn it into a Kings Indian attack not
the case here so I've played some lines
with Knight c3 I'm going to give the
tirage variation ago this tends to fit
in well with the positional minded
player we could get quite an imbalance
with Knight c3 Bishop b4 so very often
well what could happen is that black
will be saddled with an isolated pawn
however I don't see that as being the
case here
so
and I guess we're going down this path
where I grab a little bit of space and I
goes to d7 c5 and I'm not too familiar
with these lines should be perfectly
honest II 597 and then like f4 c3
supporting the center I could try for
that let's see yeah let's put it on why
not
so I have a little bit of space now
question here is can I get in out for
I'm going to play up for I'm not
developing I'm putting some great value
here on my e5 pawn so taking some time
out to make sure he stays put and I'm
considering making another pawn move a
lot of pawn moves so far but I really
want to maintain the e5 pawn I want to
also keep control over the c5 square I
want to do a lot of things here do I
have the time to do it
controlling c5 is important
controlling c5 while maintaining my d4
pawn let's say controls the knight on b7
so I'm looking at this position in a way
where I'm trying to control to a certain
extent the d7 night
control him I control him or at least I
have a little bit more information about
the bishop I'll have to be deployed
along this diagonal be tough to make use
of d7
so I think I could start out with just
c3 and it may be the case that this
Knight occupies f3 and then I get out of
my bishops way some
spending a lot of time here because I
just want to make sure I organize my
pieces in a good way I want to get a
favorable set up it could be difficult
for me to defend d4 I'm anticipating
Queen b6
black is currently ready to win the d4
pawn so let's put this nut here
maybe I can get in Bishop d3 and 92
I'd like to get those moves in first
before committing the bishop in fact b2
may be sensitive I try to deploy the
bishop too soon
there should be three maybe there's some
critical line kicking off with Queen b6
I'm not sure
I don't think I would be too concerned
over a bishop check I think I have a
couple interesting replies to that one
is to simply block I know I'm working
with a space advantage and generally one
should shy away when you have a space
shy away from peace exchanges when you
have a space advantage but another take
on this is that
would be trading my bad bishop for their
good bishop if something like this is to
occur Bishop d2 should be quite alright
and the other move I was thinking I
could maybe run with his king to f2 if I
was really trying to you know
by this principle of not trading too
many pieces when you have a space
advantage so okay well let's just follow
through here
is this their idea we're going to play
Bishop to b4 I like that black made this
decision yeah I like that black made
this decision so quick reason being that
C 3 is now vacated and I could consider
a quick transfer of my king Knight to c3
it's kind of funny Queen night is
playing here the King Knight is playing
here
acquire these positions
when you can also get it in with two
okay well what's the point of a five how
should I react to that
well how do organize here this is
interesting moment
should I take some time out to stop
anything any piece from arriving on b4
or am i okay with allowing let's say
Bishop d3 night before and I back up
think that there I don't think that
black would be in time to key in on any
of these squares that the nighttime
before is observing and I think in the
end black is kind of losing time Bishop
d3 night before Bishop to b1
eventually I give him a boot he goes
back and okay I'll still need to take
some time out to move my bishop from b1
but I don't really see that as so much
of an inconvenience
and the other option is to maybe I mean
look at the weakness that is there's two
gaps in blacks position now so maybe I
should key in on the b5 square
quick 92 to c3
trying to take advantage of two things
you know black helping me to vacate c3
and the hole on b5 would there be any
downside without
I'm gonna say no I'm gonna shoot for
that
it's kind of funny how these nights are
soon to be positioned
if you're just seeing
the moves you would think that this is a
king night and once he's here you would
think that's the queen night
so what does black do in the meantime
what kind of pawn breaks may black be
eyeing up okay so I don't have any fear
of the cleanup taking up the b6 post and
intensifying pressure here alright right
around this point I'm thinking I don't
even want to move my dark square bishop
alright let's let's follow through swing
the bat around I need to move him there
need to get my light square bishop
playing and I may just kind of work
around a knight that's on the c-4 square
my bishop does a pretty fine job of
keeping a knight on c4 under control
have to be have to be careful about
giving up my light square bishop
this is my batter Bishop and so
exchanging him off for a night even in
some situations if I'm to let's say win
a black pawn let's say my queen is on b3
and the nitrogen jumps into c4 takes
takes takes I'm up upon but I've given
up
Bishop pair I've also given black access
to the d5 square and my d4 pawn may
become a bit more vulnerable it is after
all and a half open file in this Bishop
could maybe one day turn out to be a
great pest okay
so
I think I could put my bishop on d3 I
can try to show in this position type
that my life scribe Bishop is miles
better than theirs so I should probably
put it on a really nice dog andand I
think it'd be quite scary for black to
Castle kingside know what that's another
question I have where's the king going
now that this pawn has been committed
and they go king side I have this space
invader pawn bishop bearing down right
at h7 there's some tricks maybe one day
captures on h7 Knight g5 Queen h5 so let
me revisit this variation here with
Bishop d3 Knight d4 my still okay with
backing up
and then one move later giving him a
boot
I think I am
yeah I think I'm quite alright with that
so
you know there isn't a fast way for
black to
key in on these squares with the night
on b4 so
point I'm thinking that there's maybe an
improvement for black I think this is
maybe too much too slow of an approach
there are any grave weaknesses in in the
black position okay yeah maybe maybe b5
but uh
to be on okay squares it's kind of
tricky I'm definitely feeling a bit more
free with my pieces you know both my
nights are and this sweet spot of the
board you know really well placed nights
this is a fantastic Bishop I'm ready to
Castle I'm not early on what was I doing
I was drawing some attention to yeah I
know I'm making a lot of pawn moves I'm
wasting time too I'm devoting some time
let's say not wasting time but I'm
devoting a lot of time to reinforcing my
e5 point and it appears at least that
black is giving me has given me some
time
to maintain my pawn presence in the
center I think it has good support in
other words
so this is interesting I'm starting to
see now the idea that black has
this nights looking too keen on c4 I'm
getting the impression that I'm just
going to have to be content with working
around a piece on the c-4 square they
have to do this and work to be one to
defend here and only then to pull my
dark square bishop
right around this point as well I think
I want to play a three as otherwise a
three hips by black and then I'm just
never getting rid of a knight on b4 and
I think he would be too great a bother I
know I'm weakening b3 they could fork my
rook and Bishop one day but I'd be okay
giving up my dark square bishop that's
my bad bishop so do I have what other
what am i candidate moves in just this
castles let's get a three and six
twenty-three twelve moves in so I
imagine that that's an interesting idea
got one pawn restricting to
that counts for something so let's see I
should be on the lookout for an f5 break
maybe in a situation where this pond
does not have support I can get this in
a bit easier takes and then I could
scoop up d5 I don't think he's going to
be going anywhere fast I think this
makes a lot of sense and it's it would
certainly be consistent it ties in well
with a 4 you open up the a 4 square and
you bring this knight in here one other
candidate moves well the bishop doesn't
have so many options I'll kind Knight a5
it is ok
well probably just castle here 9b3 rook
to be one
yeah
can't really uh
a bishop
let's see
we'll be night be three or nine to see
four definitely I'm not taking a night
when it arrives on c4 it's too valuable
and I'll get anything for
be different if maybe black had to take
with the pawn and I would have some
really great reason to make use of e4
but that's just not the case here some
rough moves I'm thinking Queen to e2
Bishop to e3 rip to c1 but it's going to
depend on which one of these squares
black wants to occupy with the night if
there is a knight occupy C form
this kind of gives my knight on c3 a bit
more security in a way
because you know when the rook goes to
this half-open file there won't be any
direct pressure on the knight
I have to be on the lookout for tactics
on a3 there soon going to okay they're
gone in for night b3 this is the move
that I feared less somehow okay I don't
have many options
I got this covered
some offsetting nights here on b3 and f3
uhh
up here they going to sink another night
into this square now this might be a
case where I I would capture the night
as mentioned maybe I can make use of
this here takes takes maybe even then d5
so this creates a weakness on G 6 H 6
how can I take advantage of these
weaknesses if at all
is now time to maybe look to challenge
this night so for example this and then
Knight to d2 it may be interesting
I think I should get my bishop playing
even one of these things I'd like a dark
square Bishop exchange one step closer
to maybe arriving at a good night versus
bad bishop position I'd really like to
one day play against the light square
Bishop lacks light square bishop so
light square bishop specific position or
one of my Knights versus the light
square bishop basically I don't want any
minor pieces to exchange themselves off
for the light square bishop I got a play
bit faster let's do something and I'm
pretty sure is okay so a bit of a
changing of the guard on d4 I may
challenge this piece that's pretty deep
in my position but for the time being
I'm working around them quite alright
let's see is he enough of about
that I would want to do this have this
defended this seems supernatural for up
to c8 not yet committing the bishop
although well yeah where will he go
is he going to go here to kind of watch
over these squares we'll see
cleany - I don't like that that's Knight
is controlling c1 rook to c8 is already
threatening Bishop takes pawn pawn takes
rook takes Knight so how am i dealing
with that actually hmm Wow
there's soon going to be I think rook c8
connected with Knight c4 that's going to
be tough to deal with interesting very
interesting
oh okay I'm under five
what other moves my black run with here
rook c8 how am i defending against this
tactic bishop takes a three do I have to
go Queenie one to defend do I have time
for
Knight to d2 and takes I step my queen
up and my Queens defending hmm may I
have to one day take out a knight that's
on c4 okay they're not they're not
they're not going in for Rick to c8 I'm
pretty sure the computer be lighting up
let's rip to see for now I think I need
to before it gets
there's too many pieces breathing down
my neck over here on the Queen side I
think I need to get rid of one of them
you for this kind of stuff but the I
think the more pressing issue here is to
deal with this night before maybe I'm
before it's too late
I think I need to get rid of this guy
and uh you know might even be an idea I
could reposition my night or maybe even
just get them out of the way right night
to a to
too much of a bother so
so we're going to challenge this night
get out of my house man get out now
they've created some irreparable
weaknesses on the kingside
five and G six there's a lot of gaps
over here this is the main one that's
lighting up for me
f6 mind it might as well consider g5 as
a whole could be controlled but I can
always take out the pawn that looks to
control g5 so dark square weaknesses is
basically what's lighting up in my mind
over here there are dark square
weaknesses in blacks camp
would be a fan I would be a fan of a
dark square bishop exchange bad bishop
for good Misha
that runs through my mind a lot plays a
big role
okay
teach a concept to be familiar with
okay so what options does black have
here I should just point out that I'm
ready to win upon so he is hit twice now
so let's see Knight takes Knight I will
be improving my queen
you know Knight takes Knight Queen takes
Knight c4 I think I could maybe even
take yeah in a way
could have the structure change where
black acquires a three versus two but it
would be an unhealthy three versus two
there's a there's a there would be a big
gap on B for a hole on b4 and if I get a
d5 break in you know I may be able to
make my e5 pawn mobile one day and he
could he could strike with its timely
push and maybe change the kingside
structure I get to determine that it
happens on my on my terms
so
variation something like this takes
takes d5 and then black is confronted
with a tough decision I would imagine if
you take then you're inviting me to
recapture and improve my night and he's
a beast and be a beast on d5 and if you
don't take well this pawn may even
stepped you know just continue pushing
and I have a connected past pawn that's
two steps away from queening
interesting
now you're saying no thanks
I don't want that trade
okay noted
hmm
do I have any just forceful right
through now I mean they're just taking
there I don't have enough going on
thinking Queenie one so they're going to
look then you're going to quickly now
keen on c4 I'll take once
I'm not quite sure my night is doing
there maybe one day if you could occupy
d3 but hmm I'm under three thinking
Queen to e1 to kind of over protect my
night here
or maybe rook here rook c8 rook C 294 I
take once the knight recaptures and then
I drop my bishop back to c1 that might
be a good way to organize thing kind of
like that rook c1 rook c8 rook see - one
night jumps in I take they recapture and
then I drop back here I think that's
really good harmony
you know I think I like the coordination
that results
and long improving my rock
are they going to look to jump in right
now at a moment where I wouldn't have
this convenient under developing move
my rook is in the bishops way so here
here here
I will take I think that's a favorable
structural change for light they're
under three now
very interesting middlegame battle
static structure autoplay on the
queenside some prophylactic type moves
on blacks end to kind of negate my f5
break I just want things to kind of
settle down here I want trying to make
sure things are under control on the
Queen side before I take further action
elsewhere and elsewhere for me is the
king side
where I have a space advantage
but this is taking
long time because black is keeping me
very preoccupied so here we are
moment of truth
well these two are struck out I think I
have to go in for it so big decision now
Knight takes pawn takes this is what I
was referring to so this is a case now
where I do I think I do do well to take
this Knight out and now push with d5 so
I'm going to go for it it's my better
Bishop but now I think this is the key
move is otherwise it have to be very
timely I don't push now c6 I may not
ever be able to push another alternative
is maybe Knight here but I don't like
that
I think Bishop here and even if I'm
winning upon this Bishop is really
strong as pointing this out before some
push and
this must be the way forward now if I
could somehow get moves in like this
dark square bishop exchange and just
camp out on one of these - I'd love that
okay one 112 left thinking d5 I'm going
to go with d5 yeah it may turn into an
opposite colored Bishop bending and who
I'm sure how I feel about that oh you
know what I may have a positional
sacrifice idea here if pawn takes maybe
I don't even take back I might be able
to camp out here that's tough it's tough
pawn takes Knight takes Bishop e7 Bishop
takes Knight clean takes I would really
like to get on this dog and I don't see
how I pull this off I'm pretty sure I'll
be taking with the Queen on pawn takes
pawn things are opening up you have to
keep your eyes peeled
or tactics unprotected pieces this guy's
unprotected so and it takes takes okay
let's just put it on right jump right in
there now to play Bishop here or here
fish you can still jump in takes takes
Queen takes bishop to d4 skewer also
bishop bishop here I have Bishop to c5
so the bishop has to go to e7 yeah they
overlook this so now that I think
they're just never castling at least
King side oh oh you know what I have
something even better maybe I'm just
seeing this now I'm converging on this
b6 square so Bishop to b6 the clean
moves and then Knight to c7 is a back
breaker do they have anything fancy
against me on that forty seconds so now
I'm converging on one square
be six I think this is a killing now
Bishop to b6
so now checks against me tacking they're
clean what could be a great reply no
checks against my king is there a
counter-attack against my queen
there isn't okay Bishop here but I could
just duck and prove my clean right going
to d4 and this is this is still hitting
the king will be on castled I'll be up
the exchange
it may even be the case that I'm up a
full rook somehow there at 22 seconds 22
moves in what are they going to decide
on Queen h4
can't really do that and god I've got to
go here one of these two they're going
to make a move
yes they are let's jump in have
something better let's say them or to
check winning a full rook because i take
the rook and then here i get the bishop
so insert a check first I don't see any
reason to do that just take bishop here
I have this and they just resigned
Wow very interesting game as mentioned
yeah the strategic battle there
not very lengthy move wise but uh you
know they're saying there mister the
tactic yeah
v6
okay so before I go over with the
analysis yeah they're asking
/ with the analysis well I mean you know
I don't know let's see yeah I think I
was able to voice most of what was
really running through my head
so yeah namely this this capture I felt
was a bit premature because it gave me
this idea for example if black held off
one move didn't make this capture and
instead went with a five let's say a
five was played first here let's say a
five okay I have to actually just put on
the analysis board here let me cut that
out
so if they didn't take and they played
here instead or even Queen to b6 you
know what am I doing here I'm not so I
can't just play Knight to e2 so easily
now because I don't have a follow up
square to jump into c3 so this is this
help me some because of this capture
opening up c3 gave me an additional
possibility that I otherwise would not
have had
so
they should keep the tension is what I'm
getting at I believe at least and I
wouldn't have had this type of
reposition but even so I know what a
queen side battle and these variations I
think it was like much earlier on I was
emphasizing how you know I don't want to
take a knight that arrives on c4 and
then things change because I had an
opportunity to then change the structure
with d5
now you b3 maybe maybe this is the other
one this would be the other point
instead of h5 instead of h5 maybe the
computer would prefer rip to c8 with the
knight jumping in here so I'm curious
maybe about in this position so I look
at it with the engine but right around
here if they do rook c8
Brooksie - is what I had in mind here
taking once and on night takes I can
back up
in these tactics on 83 are not working
Knight takes pawn takes I have coverage
and one day maybe even this rook can
swing over here
so now I've consolidated let's say
inside and now I'm ready to maybe push
through somehow on the kingside maybe
that could even involve just some
sacrifice work it's still the big
question I have is you know where's the
king going soon as a five was in going
Queen side is kind of out maybe maybe
not you know in a way Black has such a
grip on the Queen side hmm it's kind of
tough to get in but uh with the Riccardi
on c1 but I don't know if they could
like clogged up c4 first I just I don't
think they should go King side is what
I'm getting at because these guys here
some kind of push maybe even g4 takes
Queen takes and there's just too many
white pieces nearing the black King
okay well let's see what the graph is
saying
is what they have to say okay
interesting
okay
um I guess I didn't make any slips
hmm okay that's good news
we're the improvements are the calling
three mistakes on blacks and
so where are these mistakes exactly
are the is it at the position here no
that's not regarded as a mistake but
what is the suggestion here instead of
captures the other suggestion is to push
but I was pointing out 85 instead of
captures are clean to be six think it's
right around this point they'll be
multiple moves for black but I think
this black does well in short to simply
maintain the tension for the reasons
pointed out earlier they took
Bishop d2 I would have been fine with
Bishop or Bishop b4 I would have met
with Bishop d2 no problem and now a5 I
feel like I've somehow seen a computer
do this before I don't know
a little bit fuzzy on that so okay this
is where I went in for a knight on c3
where are the mistakes here
I mean it's 0.3 so I guess maybe one
started to open up it likes night to be
three I'm not playing with day to know
that just does not make any sense to me
I would like to just stay one square
away from getting on an open file
instead of being completely out of play
and yeah or it could be one g6 Bishop
there h5 so something was lost here it's
not regarding that as a mistake but yeah
it likes rook to c8 so yeah he could do
without I guess they didn't want to see
g4 and this but here's the thing if
there is some fear by black of g4 this
is met with h5 or now I have to react to
this threat first first of all and I
would have a night to a to move it's
pointing this out in the game just get
my knight basically out of the line of
fire
that's a I guess an additional benefit
of a three and that I didn't realize
until many moves later
you see that in like a royal up has h3
9h to reposition kind of have that going
on over here as well with the a2 square
so yeah rip to c8 seemed more to the
point kind of taking an approach where
you say you know let me make sure I
activate all my pieces first and then
maybe do these tidying up type of moves
you can't always go by the hat but you
know black has had this idea to I guess
probably stop g4 but even if there
wasn't some tactic let's say repeat was
played can I even play g4 it feels like
h5 is there okay so I guess maybe I am
hitting pretty fast with f5 and on takes
I'm able to crash through and give up my
night mate in five hmm yeah so this does
hit pretty fast so I could I could see
why black would want to stop g4 so but
you know this is I have black has some
punches that they're throwing against my
clean side here I don't have time for g4
or do I still says it's equal okay let's
go with the move played h5 night to d2
doesn't like night to d2 okay I just I
want to play Queen to c2 that doesn't
make much sense let's go to the open
file this is this is something but yeah
I just want to get rid of their night
and they retreated there's a link
see one
to see one and yeah after this it just
it's it's liking this structural change
so are we arriving now at the mistake
here after I take Knight takes e4 as a
mistake this is where they goofed and
now it's I guess just losing from here
yeah it's it's gone after that move
because I do get to give up my bishop
and have this favorable structural
change and tough decision now deal with
the knight that's on d5 and ready to
pounce on f6 or as in the game Bishop b6
or cope
one day maybe a
connected past pawn that's really really
deep in blacks position but apparently
there's even better here the no suit
freedom of no castling allowed about
Bishop to e7
there goes d6 only now it's tempo and
now here comes the knight so this is
just some serious serious dark square
weaknesses can only imagine the dark
square Bishop exchange in the night here
he's worth
can probably three pawns something out
of the ballpark
so yeah
it's just a favorable structural change
so what black should have done is
captured with the pond and I would have
played this because I need to take some
care over this and now Bishop to c6 a
totally different ballgame now because
we're having a bad Bishop for a good
Bishop exchange clean the f3 and I think
I I think I would have played a move
like clean a string because this this is
a
double ponds right they look very ugly
but look at the support this pond is now
lending to d5 and what's going to happen
is that black is going to have an
enormous night versus a super tall pond
yeah I'm I'm preferring black in this
position I know it's reading 0.3 but I
would prefer to play black this bishop
controls the night
offsetting and what do you turn to next
we're going to have a super strong night
versus this guy and I don't know what
his future is
so and I think it still would have
turned out like that I mean here let's
say Queen okay this is a little bit
different I mean I would have an option
one day to maybe take
and then have some kind of break like
this and wow this is a very interesting
endgame they have the better bish
I have some space in the center but yeah
they have some space over here on the
queenside yeah this sort of you know
this would have made a pretty
interesting end game if it came to that
but I guess in the end they're just they
really just underestimated the power of
the this keep on break d5 and as
mentioned it has to be super timely if I
say to myself at this point okay I don't
have a flight square let's maybe make a
fly square for my king
things just shift right away I don't get
in this advance and they take over
control of d5 they have the bishop Haran
and unopposed Bishop that knifes right
into my King position and it's just no
good but uh yeah it's just gone from
here Bishop to b6 I imagine there's
other good moves but keying in on that
one Square follow-up 97 and it's just
gone it's not the exchange it's a full
rook Queen takes Knight Queen takes
Bishop okay well interesting game out of
the what was it French tirage I think at
least anyhow feel free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you're having
a good day and I will catch you soon
that's all for now take care bye
you
you